[Music]
and team again news submitted by JK kids
Oh what's a group a woman fell into a
coma and woke up believing she was cell
team again yeah what's that movie heard
dude sound like that yeah yeah yeah they
switch bodies though in that movie right
no she is logged if you're thinking of
another one
oh you think you're Freaky Friday yep
that's all I gots Lindsay Lohan yeah
yeah man she used to be hot what
happened to her crack just a lot of
drugs just that whole childhood
Hollywood life she got her parents she
hasn't it's not her fault
yeah this woman her name was Shannon 22
from the UK again yeah she was giving
birth to her second child and during the
labor she ended up saying like looking
over to her husband and her fiance and
her mother and saying like I love you
and she passed out and well she didn't
just pass out for 68 minutes she died
hard for 68 minutes baby birth they she
ended up going unconscious unconscious
and the baby came out still the doctors
they had to get the baby with like horse
EPS and stuff oh she was pregnant she
was giving birth when she heard she was
in the living room oh [ __ ]
so she went through a portal back in
time through her delivery after her
heart stopped the doctors put her in a
coma for two weeks in order for her to
recover because for that amount of time
like her brain wasn't getting any longer
yeah her whole body and so luckily they
were still able to save her and so
coming out of the coma
that's when she woke up and she didn't
realize that she had two kids that she
had a fiancee is she in her head when
her mom asked her like you know where do
you think we live right now she gave an
address from when she was 13 years old
and like she just thinks like she's 13
now
does she look in a mirror go how the
hell did I guess I'll owe you probably
she doesn't remember being pregnant she
doesn't remember her kids like she was
my best sup and like the it affected her
brain so much too that she's lost like
all of her like motor skills and so she
has to learn she has to relearn
everything so her and her baby are going
to the same stages that sort of fiance
that like you know we thought we were
going to be coming home with one baby
but we ended up going home so she pushed
so hard that I have a remember you got
erased was cause her heart stopped and
like it's crazy that I feel like she's
such a good person because during like
times of like peril and I'm about to
like die I don't think I like curse
everybody else like she felt it coming I
felt something so you see that [ __ ] with
those people who go into a coma and they
woke up wake up and they speak a
different language that's pretty crazy
how was that even possible I want to
know like the psychology behind that
[ __ ] like they'll wake up and they're
like straight-up American and then when
they wake up they're speaking fluent
French makes no sense and they never
even been there before if I ever try to
learn the language anything and they're
like well that's just how amazing our
brain is they probably heard someone
else speak that mean you're able to like
Sabrina should unlock bad I'll try to
learn other languages too it does exist
you can't tap into it though limitless
help take it and then tap into like the
matrix learning thing or that too so I
need this [ __ ] download that ships
yeah
but you know what they say right it's
like we already know a lot of [ __ ] but
these Indies doesn't connect what did
you point out and this is not connecting
that's it has to connect and then that's
when you're in the zone and then you're
smarter than you think you are if I knew
I would do it but all the greats all the
great like I don't know artists and
convene all like comedians or musicians
like they have control of that that's
why they can produce great [ __ ]
I need that help Shannon she the mother
she dresses like a 12 year old that the
labor that's right no oh she is what she
ought to come with what she's wearing
nothing I'm saying this is like a young
teenagers outfit really yes like a
junior high spot you get high outfit oh
really you probably has like those
bell-bottoms like those flare jeans do
you wear this like a regular tank top
with the white cardigan looks like a
thirteen-year-old teen girls elfia I'm
saying I think it's because she probably
has the piercings I get it like and oh I
didn't see the can't see that from over
here I'm not knocking or anything I'm
just saying it looks like yeah she
dresses young okay the the piercing
definitely makes her look not like a
mama yeah now she looks like a mom the
cute ass kid oh really young yeah 22 oh
she was gonna say that the husband looks
lesbians look like two women let me see
no from this angle to it look like two
women so I'm like wait what happened a
little a two woman's no beyond thing
yeah still looks like knocking the duty
just like all the way up here wait till
Tiger stance yeah this is why after
after she woke up from her coma
so she didn't get to hold her baby for
the first 200 the baby didn't get to
feel his mama waking up as like he's
about the pop lock is it is waking up
being 13 though like does she ever freak
out it's seeing her own child like I'm
sure they don't really go into detail
like how she's been reacting that much
but they do mention though that she
ended up seeing like some video some
past video of her daughter her firstborn
and it kind of like jog your memory a
bit about her so it's like a slow
process is the 51st day I woke up as a
13 year old like my own 13 year old self
in this like present state fog that'd be
[ __ ] awesome log into my bank account
one night I'll go back and blast all my
teachers Oh crazy it'll be the same [ __ ]
I would really do it I would ruin this
life right now
yeah I would ruin and save where to weed
at word yeah
and I will go to raves like this is
[ __ ] dope this is way better than
Master Dome what aisle five I was 13 it
and I ended up looking at myself now I'd
be so mad dude where the [ __ ] is my
six-pack you [ __ ] [ __ ] fuzz like
what happened I look at my bank account
nothing's changed I'm so mad I had a kid
so young just four years later statistic
she did it again talk about a Mexican
statistic some family member said when I
got pregnant they're like why do you do
deep and is he wearing a leather hat
yeah they look hella young dude yeah you
look really young they're like no more
than like 22 well yeah she's 22 oh she
is oh you didn't hear me earlier yeah
she's doing pretty good hey that's
pretty good young family everything we
have to be very appreciative of what we
have sometimes I see about other people
code throughout my [ __ ] man I going
through that yeah you know I mean like
we have all of our motor functions we
don't have any issues like that I don't
have any of that stuff you take
everything from I have a baby actually I
don't have a baby but I'm saying like
when Mariel you know she has a baby I
hope she'd have to go through stuff like
that yeah that's scary I mean you you
put yourself at risk man [ __ ] kids
you're the type thing is though that
child can never ever talk back to her
like I [ __ ] went through everything
just like you did I don't know how to
walk like a [ __ ] marionette puppet is
[ __ ] I could've [ __ ] no and they were
trying for their second kid for three
years they've been together for six
years they have a three year olds like
right after they had that child I'm
assuming they just immediately wanted
another one and so they've been trying
and so and then all this happens giving
birth to that second kids it's crazy did
the doctors ever explain like exactly
why it happened when her heart stopped
for six to eight minutes
oh she ended up having an amniotic
embolism that's two words to me that is
two words amniotic fluid embolism so
it's the finest it's a rapid collapse of
a mother
that's right joke due to an allergic
like reaction when amniotic fluid enters
the mother circulation Oh Shh I didn't
even know that was possibly I've been
one and every 40,000 pregnancies in the
US that's a lot more in Europe it's one
in every fifty three thousand eight
what's in the water of Europe for people
to be doing that
Amiata fluid into the circulation of the
mama's body oh they are like more people
in the earth in the u.s. maybe that's
why it's more is there eBay yeah that's
what happened to her
but luckily she's fine the baby's fine
now she just has to relearn some [ __ ]
man
and so like her mom is taking care of
her right now cuz they have she has a
sister that's disabled and so her house
is already like made for like wheelchair
accessibility so that she's been prepped
[Laughter]
he's ready for that it's just that
that's like so I just picked her mom I
liked about it he's like yep I got ready
and she's like you know weird leave you
hyped up about she's not act up she's
coming up being prepped baby yeah that's
what I feel like I feel like they have
like pillows stapled to the wall like no
one could get hurt like anybody has
[ __ ] up come to my house it's a-okay I
feel like this is how my grandma feels
because she has Alzheimer's so she's all
like in the future all the time but then
she thinks she's younger like I remember
when she went into the retirement home
she was telling my mom like look at all
these old [ __ ] like she's like look
at all these old it just changes from
time to time yeah so she told my mom
like look at all these old [ __ ] and
joined this puppet show
look thank you know I feel like I've
been having memory problems were like
I'm saying something like I don't even
happen dream J can use like I'm saying
something and then immediately like it's
gone and I'm my mind's blank I'm like
what the hell just happened so I can
only imagine how she feels like her
whole life she just can't remember
anything after 38 when the habit when
you say something it just disappears
right mid-sentence yeah I mean hey are
you gonna memory things have to take her
girl I had it before type I do remember
what she was pregnant she could have run
[ __ ] like how to speak it was weird
dude she's like yeah in your [ __ ]
face help
she wasn't fun for me at all suck no
kids like after Isaac I forgot people I
went to high school with and then I see
them after I'm like don't you remember
we had that class together and I'm like
what I'm not even pregnant that happens
to me right now yeah me too
me too I've even watched some of our old
skits like damn that's me but how to
remember doing this your life becomes I
think a lot more fast-paced when you're
older to like you just those things just
start to get ditched you know I mean
because people my high school reunion
like yo man I'm like [ __ ] are you when
you learned something you kind of
replace it with something else maybe
even people where we only have the
capacity to remember like a hundred
people with significance yeah or maybe
it goes until that part of your brain
you can't tap into like it's still there
but you just thought well you know the
French and the Japanese and it's all in
there yeah Oh too much brain work
[Music]